Final Fantasy games have always been
emotional Affairs you laugh you cry you
get really angry but let's focus on that
crying part here are 10 moments from
throughout the series that trust your
emotions and broke your heart
we couldn't list the 10 saddest moments
in Final Fantasy without this iconic
moment while trying to summon holy so
clouds gang can save the world
Sephiroth skewers poor Aerith just as
she finishes praying to add insult to
injury not only is our hero seconds away
from saving her
when Aerith dies you lose all the
material you had equipped her with we
were visit this moment again and again
in the film Advent Children where cloud
is repeatedly visited by aerith's spirit
as she guides him in his fight against
the Sephiroth clones and who didn't
burst into tears at the end she walked
away into the light of the lifestream
tragic Black Mage Phoebe struggles with
the meaning of life after watching this
senseless slaughter of the Black Mage
army Phoebe comes to believe that life
is expendable only to learn soon after
that it's also not permanent when Black
Mage describes how another stopped
moving he says quote unquote mister 36
is buried under the ground now but I
don't understand why he's going to come
out again one day right Phoebe learns
that death is not just for the sick and
injured death comes for us all his
existential crisis is powerful and a
little frightening and although he
eventually comes to believe that life is
precious and what you make of it is up
to you watching his journey to this
point is heart-rending Orin is the stoic
guardian of Titus and then Yuna you
journey with him for 40 plus hours until
suddenly horrifyingly you learn that
he's actually been dead this whole time
in his younger days Horan went on a
pilgrimage with Yunus father braska to
defeat the evil entity sin but because
nothing is ever easy at the end of the
journey Braska and his other guardian
Titus's father jecht sacrificed their
lives to bring ten more years of peace
to the world not having any of it Orin
confronted yunalesca
the powerful undead summoner who carried
out the sacrifices furious with his
questioning yunalesca del Orin a fatal
blow to the head he died but did not
move on he stayed on this plane a living
ghost unable to rest until Tidus and
Yuna succeeded in defeating sin this is
your world now following kefka's
destruction of the world celli's wakes
up on an empty island with her adopted
father Sid Sid cares for sally's as he
himself becomes sick and weak what
happens to sit next can go one of two
ways
playing a cell ace you catch different
kinds of fish to feed him feed him the
fastest fish and he'll get well but if
you only catch the slow-moving weaker
fish Sid will die and if Sid dies you're
shown a cutscene where sillies climbs to
the top of a nearby cliff in tears and
throws herself off in a suicide attempt
she survives and wakes up on the beach
but oh man is it rough to watch it's
very rare for such a mainstream game to
tackle suicide at all and you can feel
sillies pain her despair at losing
everyone she loves is so great she just
can't make herself go on paladin
sessle's ragtag band of heroes are
joined by palem and porom two prodigal
five year old mages after a particularly
grueling battle against the archfiend
cat nazo the group is caught in a trap
as the walls around them begin to cave
in to save them all Palamon poram turned
themselves to stone preventing the walls
from closing in any further and allowing
cecil and his companions to escape you
can't heal them you can't remove them
they're just statues the fact that these
kids are barely out of their toddler
stage coupled with the whole thing
happening very abruptly is just
soul-crushing even though they reappear
later in the game fully healed by the
mysterious elder this doesn't diminish
the gut-punch of watching them sacrifice
themselves
poem poem when his son dodge turns to
Crystal following the fulfillment of his
list see focus saws breaks but then he
learns why his son was branded a lysse
to begin with Vanille and Fang tried to
kill a fal'cie and the entity branded
dodged in an effort to protect itself up
to this point
saws has been protecting Vanille
essentially his son's killer by
association with his life then saws
really breaks and turns his gun on
Vanille but she doesn't run when she
says she doesn't know how to atone for
what has happened saws drops his weapons
and resolves to die then Ana Dolan
appears a creature that will kill any
lesea who tries to die these scenes are
lore heavy and it's easy to get lost in
the proper nouns of Final Fantasy 13 s
world but that doesn't diminish the
power of watching these characters
struggle to find hope
okay fine you want me come and get me
we learn in Final Fantasy seven that
Zach died fighting Shinra soldiers in
prequel Crisis Core published a decade
after the original game you get to
participate in this moment you play
through the entire game knowing that at
the end
Zach will die and as you play through
his last stand the controls literally
stop working on you no amount of button
smashing does anything everything just
spins out of control and just as you
come to terms with the fact that you're
fighting a final boss battle that is
destined to end in failure it's done
Zach riddled with bullets passes a sort
to cloud and dies you knew this was
coming but having to actually live
through it brutal
sky pirate Redis was once a powerful
judge Magister but after being
manipulated by the scientist dr. Sid to
activate a super weapon in decimate an
entire city he left his title behind
tortured by what he'd done throughout
the game Redis offers counsel to Ashe
and her crew as well as some backup
muscle he accompanies the party to find
the sun-cryst
a stone that will grant Ashe an untold
amount of destructive power once there
the party learns that the stone has
already been activated and is powering
the Final Fantasy 12 equivalent of the
death star Redis eventually sacrifices
himself in destroying the sun-cryst
opening the way for the team to confront
the game's final boss Redis didn't have
to but chose to die which already makes
this tragic but after all you've been
through with him in the game it's tough
to cope with his sudden absence
George Rajasthan
the last we see of Lagoona and Final
Fantasy 8 he's standing at his wife's
grave after losing out on his first love
Laguna marries rain who nurses him back
to health after a botched War expedition
Laguna is called off again when
sorceress Adel kidnaps alone reigns
adopted daughter Laguna leaves not
knowing his wife is pregnant and after
eventually saving alone in defeating
adel he sends the girl home to her
mother and then becomes president for
some reason rain meanwhile dies giving
birth to her son heavily implied to be
hero squall and her two children are
sent to an orphanage Lagoona never sees
rain again and he loses nearly
everything he's ever loved in the end
sequence we see him visiting rains grave
and reliving his proposal to her after a
lifetime of heartache that's all that's
left for Laguna in the end talk about a
total downer Final Fantasy Tactics is
literally just one big series of really
unfortunate events it begins with death
ends with death and nobody is happy
Jesus Final Fantasy Tactics
what moments from the Final Fantasy
series really broke your heart let us
know in the comments below and for all
your final fantasy news stick to
GameSpot calm
you